there are currently 1 billion people
with substandard housing buildings
currently utilize and require energy
more than any other industry buildings
create more carbon than any other
industry and as we look to population
projections we're gonna have to build
more buildings in the next 30 years then
we have in the past 3000 and at the same
time those buildings are gonna have to
use so much less energy and create so
much less carbons and as an architect
it's kind of exciting because it means
that if buildings our biggest problem as
we look to the future then it means that
buildings can be our biggest solution so
I'm going to talk a little bit about my
second chapter which was doing prefab
green homes it was my humble attempt at
thinking about some of these problems
and how to make sustainable healthy
homes accessible to more people and
utilizing modular technology as a way to
do that this is a home that we built
with Wired magazine
we built this home as seven modules in a
factory and through software and through
the factory we were able to achieve 50
to 75 percent less waste depending on
the material we then set the seven
modules to the site we started setting
them at about 7:30 in the morning and by
4:30 that same day I was walking through
the house doing the check with the
Builder which was pretty exciting then
we spent the next two months doing what
we called the button upward so in total
it took four months to build the house
and if you're gonna do that with
traditional construction it would take
you 14 months we actually embedded
software into the home itself as a way
to allow us to monitor the production
and consumption of energy and water and
what's great is there a lot of
architects and a lot of companies doing
this work now which is wonderful
but it's it's not enough it's still a
small niche there's still a big world we
have to think bigger
we need improvement
really quickly this industry is still
overall so inefficient so this chart
shows us that every other industry has
been using software as a way to help
with productivity except for
construction and there are a number of
reasons for this some of which is a lot
of designers architects engineers we
don't share information so we're almost
kind of starting from scratch every time
so it's hard to really innovate other
than in incremental steps we also have
good software systems that we can use
but much of it is incompatible with one
another
there's still time consuming so we don't
have timely data that we really need for
making good decisions we don't have
instant information on cost or energy or
how the building were perform so what is
the solution for making buildings better
more accessible more affordable I have
been fortunate enough to be a part of a
team of software engineers we started
with this project a couple of years ago
at Google X and spun out our company
called fluxed the team has been looking
at this industry so I'm going to show us
just a little bit of a fully functioning
software that we've been developing
we've been in stealth mode so this is
kind of exciting to be sharing a little
peek at this of what's possible when you
connect these items this allows you to
design a building in seconds at the
speed of thought where as you're
designing it you have the data that you
really need for making good decisions as
you make changes you can see what the
cost implications will be what the
energy implications will be it
automatically gives you best practice
detailing and structural systems you can
understand when you do that what the
implications are for functionality
occupant experience initial cost but
also more importantly lifecycle cost of
the building right now this will take a
team of people
weeks months to do what this software
will allow you to do in seconds so this
gives the teams more time for innovation
and actually being able to improve as we
go along by democratizing knowledge and
tools in the building in construction
space this allows architects engineers
and building owners to share their work
like software engineers do it allows
them to collectively solve problems and
improve the process every single time
innovation goes viral
so that way things like adaptive solar
facades aren't just developed on one
building they're used on many and it
improves with each one and ideas like
genzler's breathing skin can actually
become affordable for multifamily
housing in developing countries and
things like hok is algae living facade
can be something that is commonplace and
not the exception
so by relearning from the latest logic
of software and applying it to how we
design and construct buildings we can
design our buildings in cities where we
and the planet can thrive thank you